du bist krank da gib deine symptome
einfach bei einer app ein eine maschine
wird mit dir darüber reden ähnlich wie
ein richtiger arzt nach rund 20 fragen
erstellt die maschine eine
wahrscheinliche diagnosen diese app das
zeug die medizin zu revolutionieren
er hat die app mit namen aller
mitentwickelt glaube schon dass sich die
rolle des arztes in gewisser weise
verändern wird
meine erfahrungen aus den letzten acht
jahren wo ich mit sehr sehr vielen
ärzten gesprochen und auch zusammen
gearbeitet habe ist dass die besten
ärzte diejenigen sind die sich bewusst
sind dass sie mit unterstützung von
technologie noch mal bessere ärzte sein
können acht jahre lang entwickelten
ärzte programmierer gemeinsam die app
werden tausende studien aus gesehen ist
quasi das ergebnis was er nach einer
symptom analyse liefert auf der linken
seite finden sie die symptome die bejaht
oder verneint wohnen auf der rechten
seite die möglichen erklärungen die er
liefert und haben die grünen linien die
zeit die weisen darauf hin dass ein
symptom bejaht wurde und wie stark dann
dieses argument für eine krankheit
spricht und die roten linien dass das
symptom verneint und wie stark dieses
verneinen im gegen bestimmte krankheiten
spricht rund um den globus wird die app
genutzt sie liegt mit ihrer diagnose
meist richtig
die trefferquote liegt ungefähr so hoch
wie bei einem echten arzt um die
trefferquote weiter zu verbessern nutzen
die macher der app künstliche
intelligenz
der selbst lerne faktor besteht darin
dass wir aus den aus den ergebnissen die
er liefert und das feedback was die user
darauf geben ob das gestimmt hat was für
eine diagnose beziehungsweise erklärung
geliefert hat daraus kann die künstliche
intelligenz theoretisch lernen
für uns ist halt wichtig dass das nicht
automatisch passiert sondern dass immer
ärzte dazwischen sind die das
entscheiden ob diese änderungen sinnvoll
ist oder nicht damit vermeiden wir das
einfach user in welche sachen erzählen
die gar nicht stimmen
und wie schlägt sie sich im alltag zur
us coach im indischen jaipur ist einer
der sieben millionen app-nutzer die
sprache könnte einfacher gehalten sein
so dass mehr leute die es verstehen
stoffwechselkrankheiten diabetes oder
fettleibigkeit sollten auch erfasst
werden mit entsprechenden ernährungs
hinweisen
bei ihrer analyse warnt die app die
patienten bei möglichen ernsthaften
erkrankungen sollten sie zum arzt gehen
superstar könnte unter einer entzündung
der nasenhöhle leiden dass
diagnostiziert auch der arzt musste
christian ganz die meisten symptome
seiner krankheit hat die software
korrekt erkannt das ist gut ich denke
dass die app den arzt nicht ersetzen
wird weil die klinische untersuchung
sehr wichtig ist aber die app ist ein
sinnvolles hilfsmittel die künstliche
intelligenz könnte in zukunft so die
hoffnung der entwickler krankheiten
schon kommen sehen bevor die user selbst
diese bemerken
ich denke dass auch keine sicherlich ein
beitrag dazu leisten wird dass leute
länger gesünder leben können und vor
allem dass krankheiten oft gar nicht
erst entstehen gerade da will ich da
auch hin
dafür muss das system über viele jahre
den user begleiten und seine daten
sammeln
das könnte so manchen unbehagen bereiten
auch wenn die app macher immer wieder
betonen die daten gehören dem user
allein und werden nur anonymisiert
ausgewertet
höhere lebenserwartung für weniger
privatsphäre
das gehört wohl zur ki medizin wild dazu